[Musique]
voilà mayotte coupés du monde depuis ce
matin toutes les liaisons aériennes
suspendu pour 15 jours au moins la
présence du variant sud africain a été
détectée début janvier à mayotte le
dépistage s'accélère la préfecture
renforce les mesures pas de déplacement
non plus vers la réunion
ces deux départements sont en effet les
plus proches de l'afrique du sud dans ce
pays
le nouveau variant beaucoup plus
contagieux que la souche classique met à
genoux tout le système sanitaire
la situation est hors de contrôle dans
les hôpitaux publics les patients sont
soignés sur les parkings faute de place
d'autres patients décèdent dans les
ambulances car il n'y a pas de lits pour
les prendre en charge
l'afrique du sud est littéralement
submergé par ses deuxième vague de toute
façon la france défend l'idée que les
pays de l'union européenne doivent
rester totalement ouvert c'est pour ça
vous dit idéologique mais bien sûr c'est
idéologique c'est parce qu'ils défendent
la libre circulation à tout prix au prix
de la santé de nos compatriotes et donc
au prix de notre économie
marine le pen ment aux français et fait
croire que rien n'est fait non les
frontières ne sont pas des passoires non
il y à des mesures importantes qui ont
été pris de longue date d'autres mesures
qui dès maintenant aujourd'hui sont en
application et sont renforcés cantons
faisant de l'étranger un test pcr
négatif est nécessaire et voilà un
gouvernement qui nous expliquent qu'il
faudrait d'abord prendre le pouls des
plus réticents avant de s'occuper de ce
qu'ils veulent il ya des visites est
majoritaire il était mais peu importe on
sait très bien comment les choses se
passent vous avez quand même des gens au
départ qui disent bon on va voir éditeur
puis après ils voient et donc il faut
profiter de la phase d'entraînement des
premiers pour pouvoir ensuite avoir les
seconds
si le gouvernement encore une fois nous
impose un état d'urgence sanitaire pour
pouvoir prendre des mesures qu'il prend
en vase clos avec un président de la
république qui s'enferme dans son bunker
avec 10 15 personnes et qu'ils décident
entre eux sans écouter ce qui se dit
dans le pays des élus locaux au
parlement
je le regrette c'est la démocratie qui
est bafouée
cette folie là encore idéologie
emmanuel macron consistant à dire on va
gouverner avec des sachants avec des
experts
on va confier non pas aux responsables
politiques élus mais à des pseudo
spécialistes qui d'ailleurs ne sont
d'accord sur absolument rien le soin de
déterminer la conduite du pays
cet hymne un effondrement sur le plan de
l'efficacité que vous deviez un vrai
problème de commande de vaccins je suis
désolé l'europe n'a pas commandé assez
les pays qui s'en sortent bien sont ceux
qui en réalité on en commander en plus
par eux mêmes c'est l'exemple de
l'allemagne c'est l'exemple d'un certain
de ne pas dévoiler leurs problèmes en
europe et on n'a pas les mêmes
informations non là haut qu on va
écouter ce n'est pas le cas même si un
certain nombre d'autres pays en ont
commandé eux-mêmes
on a voulu faire le test avec quelques
stars de la politique wassim annuel
macron votre si jean castex version
dessin animé disney regardez jean michel
blanquer
ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal hein
regardez là c'est marine le pen comment
voulez vous qu'on ne soit pas d'effrayer
anxieux face à tout ce qui est en train
d'être venir d'autant plus anxieux qu'on
a des perspectives bien évidemment grâce
à ces vaccins notamment grâce aux soins
les choses vont aller mieux mais on ne
peut pas dire quand une vraie perf
l'ascension du fameux k2 en plein hiver
c'est une première c'est une équipe
d'alpinistes népalais qui a réussi cet
exploit
j'ai été malade et soigné j'ai pas une
forme j'ai une forme médiane et ça s'est
bien passé nous sommes remis moins forte
que celle de votre mari différentes
perte de goût perte d'odorat fait ig
migraine son ascension est réputée comme
étant l'ascension la plus difficile au
monde
alors bravo à cette équipe l'expédition
qui a quand même
néanmoins été ternie par la mort d'un
alpiniste espagnol la disparition de
serge emig gauthé 49 ans rappelle que
l'ascension du k2 est considérée comme
la plus difficile au monde
80 alpinistes qui ont déjà trouvé la
mort